i was quoting at one point and saying
this is a tremendous glimpse of the
obvious
why you've got patents on it and why
hasn't anyone done it before
the invention is a pair of variable
power eyeglasses
essentially what you have is a chamber
bounded by thin plastic membranes
changing the amount of fluid in the lens
changes the curvature of the surfaces
i cover up one eye i then adjust the
lens until i've got nice clear focus i
chop off these tubes and that's it i
made eyeglasses without needing the
attention of a professional
in britain you have roughly one optician
per 5 000 of the population if you lived
in sub-saharan africa the ratio would be
nearer to one optician per million
people if you live in the developing
world and you have no access to
corrective eyewear this will have a huge
impact on your life there are 40 thou
roughly 40 000 of these in use in over
20 countries in the developing world if
you actually look at the need it's a
small step on the way
i would like to see a billion people
wearing the eyeglasses they need by the
year 2020
and that's a real challenge
you